[Music]
how much fun are you having out here I
mean come on giving some mom time some
you time this is me time I'm having
something look at this I get to ChaCha
in this fun number with this guy I'm
like literally living out every mom's
guilty pleasure right but the dress
rehearsal I like you boobs the show and
so we need this rhinestone I talking to
Nick and I was asking him about how
comfortable he is in the rhinestones and
the tight pants and the hilts shoes he's
like bring it on that's what I love
about him
he said bring it on he did say on your
show that he wouldn't do this again yes
and look where he is now kids change you
man they prioritize they make your
priorities just a little more clearer
and he one day you have dreams and goals
next day you got three kids and doing
this you just are that's what happens
ladies and gentlemen life hits you in
the face
yeah wait till you have three kids and
you come talk to me he is out here with
heels and type dancing sequins over
others and good man
[Music]
take it easy match our guy who's never
ever ever ever ever gonna do dance from
the stars you did a great job I
appreciate that
yes as I said earlier kids Never Say
Never you don't know when that's gonna
come back to bite you but I'm having a
blast everything and there's a lot of
fun banter you know with the the wife
the husband have you guys checked in
tonight uh you know off camera cuz we
shoot over yeah I mean I just told her
how proud I was over I mean actually I
thought she killed it out there and I
know how hard she's worked at it and and
and and how nervous she was about it and
she just came out and rocked it so they
look at the end of the day we support
your spouse you know it's we we love who
were married to and it's great to see
them do well as well so that was a great
night for everybody
[Music]
you